and welcome back everybody Alec murdaugh
goes on trial next week for the murders
of his wife Maggie and Son Paul it
starts Monday in Walterboro South
Carolina long crimes and Jeanette Levy
tells us what's going on inside and
outside of that Courthouse as this small
City prepares for the trial of the
century
people are preparing for for that
because we want to put Walterboro in its
best light in a bad situation all eyes
will be on the Colleton County
Courthouse as the double murder trial of
Alec murdaugh begins it puts Walter at
the center of attention Walterboro is
the small city where the courthouse sits
900 potential jurors have been summoned
12 along with alternates will be
selected to hear what will be the
highest profile murder case this County
and the City of Walterboro has ever seen
we have had walterboro's had a couple of
movies filmed here and such like that so
we're used to having people in town
working in media and such like that but
the amount of targeted
um
attention at one time is just
unprecedented something happening for
the trial inside the courthouse a
portrait of Alec Murdoch's grandfather
Buster will be removed from the
courtroom before jury selection to
prevent the jury from being influenced
by the Murdoch family Legacy Alec
Murdoch's father grandfather and
great-grandfather all served as
solicitor for this area Prosecuting
cases Alec Murdoch even tried cases in
the same courtroom where he will be
tried for murder for Law and crime daily
I'm Anjanette Levy
can't make this stuff up so let's talk
about the witnesses Terry let's start
with who you think we're going to see
from the prosecution you know if the
judge allows the prosecution to tell the
full story I think we're going to see a
lot of witnesses and families that were
involved with some of the deaths
involved in Alec murdaugh so we have we
have Gloria Satterfield who was the
former you know made for the family and
she died mysteriously she fell down
steps we know that Stephen Smith also
died and of course Mallory Beach died
now if the judge allows all of that
testimony in we're going to see their
family members testifying we're going to
see family members of Myrna himself who
he stole from there's no question we're
going to see his Law Firm members
testify because he embezzled from them
and of course we're going to have
regular Witnesses like the medical
examiner we're going to have police
authorities who investigated so I think
you're going to see quite a huge list of
witnesses when this trial finally does
get underway Brian before we get
Witnesses we need jury so what do you
think the strategy is going to be in
selecting a jury by both sides in a case
like this Jesse I know what everyone
always hears when a defense attorney
will probably comes up we want a fair
jury someone who can look at all the
evidence no I want a juror who's going
to vote for my arguments and so when you
have a case where literally a family
member's portrait needs to be taken down
from the court that's polarizing of
course there's going to be people in the
community to say Hey you prosecuted you
kept us safe there's also many people to
say you prosecuted family members of
mine and I want to see your family
punished as well so when you weed
through all of those people you're going
to try to look for the prosecutor for
someone who can look at the evidence but
also say hey here's a fall from grace
story and I want to make sure that
powerful people get punished and there's
on the other side of the defense who say
hey this is a good family this is
someone who would not do this crime and
you're looking for people who would lend
themselves to that argument might not be
so easy might not be one two three
getting a jury in this kind of case
given the small town community